pandemic is dramatically changing our
lives every single day this week in our
series on the new normal we'll look at
how those changes will affect the way we
work the way we socialize the way we
learn in the way we vote this morning
the financial impact on businesses and
workers many companies are being forced
to adapt on 60 minutes last night Norah
O'Donnell as General Motors CEO that's
Mary Barra
whether the disease is a threat to GM's
long-term future between the strength of
our balance sheet with the steps we've
taken in the past we will get through
this and we will learn a lot of lessons
that will apply I mean what's the
long-term prognosis for for General
Motors if you're not making cars no one
knows when things are going to get back
to what I refer to as a new normal I've
heard others refer to it as a new
abnormal CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger joins us to discuss this I
like that Jill the new abnormal I think
that's a good way to hear to describe it
so what are you hearing from business
leaders about the ways various
industries are going to be impacted by
this pandemic there's basically three
distinct phases I'm calling it t3 so
triage what we've just gone through
everyone threw out the old playbook
there was no playbook how are we
adapting it was really done on the fly
the that triage really is important
because now many business owners are
entering the second phase trance trance
ition so triage to transition this is
where many companies are saying despite
what governors say or mayor's say or the
president says they are putting workers
safety first only critical people back
in the building and the third t
transformation what will a workplace
look like will there have to be
different kind of workspaces out there
how are we reconfiguring how we work can
more people be home working remotely are
we going to suspend business travel or
at least alter it are we going to change
the way we do our conferences more
teleconferencing so think of it that way
Trias transition which is where we are
right now transformation
boy Jill I think that applies to all of
us regardless of whether you're in
business or not so what is sticking with
the business theme what businesses will
be impacted most do you think and how
will they get through well you know you
just heard Mary Barra say something that
was really important from the automotive
sector which is look we've been through
terrible times so you think about big
businesses like the Airlines the
automotive industries they have been
through terrible times they will
probably survive maybe come out
different but we also know that
hospitality could change will Airbnb be
as popular on the other side of this we
don't know we also understand now that
there's going to be a big impact on the
oil sector here in the United States you
know crude oils down by 70% the increase
this year so all these industries I
think are going to be very much looking
like different types of themselves
coming out
Jil retail was already struggling before
the pandemic hits so how much dire a
situation more dire situation you think
they're gonna be in as we all go back to
work I think that the pandemic really
accelerates trends that were already in
place and as you said retail had a
terrible year last year ninety three
hundred stores were closed twenty three
retail bankruptcies we are hearing that
potentially this week we will get two
big chains filing for bankruptcy
that would be Neiman Marcus and JCPenney
we know that Macy's and the Gap they're
all reorganizing right now what we come
out with on the other side we know there
will be a larger reliance on online
sales obviously Amazon and Walmart and
Target doing a bumper business Dollar
General as well I think what's going to
be interesting is how we open the
nation's largest retailers are writing
together to the governments of all
governors of all the states trying to
say we need a uniform way to come back
into business because we've got
operations everywhere it's very
difficult for a retailer to have a
patchwork set of rules and procedures
coming in this transition process and
in that transformation process Jill the
last time I left the house was March
31st it was to go to CVS to pick up her
prescription if you would have told me
that it would have made sense to me to
stand six feet away to lean to her
plastic screen to throw in a credit card
and grab my stuff and get out of there I
would have thought that's impossible but
here we are so what can consumers expect
what changes can we expect as consumers
moving forward you know someone said
something really interesting to me who
owns a store and he said you know look
just because I opened doesn't mean
people will come I think we don't know
what the lasting impact of this virus
will be on consumers in some places
you're seeing people going out and
getting haircuts in other places we
don't know what I do know is that there
will be an impact it is evolving we'll
be on top of these trends but most
importantly to stay safe is probably
best for the economy as well stay safe
stay sane thank you very much Jill